I'm just telling you what we as the um
intelligence Community assesses is
happening in Gaza City so I want to show
you guys one more clip because for years
everyone has known in Israel and outside
of Israel that shifa hospital that
beneath it that's where Hamas
headquarters are that's where the
network of tunnel is that's likely where
the hostages are right now that's where
their command and Communication Center
is the whole freaking thing and of
course Andre Mitchell earlier in the
week pretended that wasn't true either
uh here's the Pentagon admitting it
finally fully publicly we do have
information that Hamas and the
Palestinian Islamic Jihad uses some
hospitals in the Gaza Strip including
the alifa hospital um as a way to
conceal and support their military
operations and hold hostages they have
tunnels underneath these hospitals and
so Hamas and P members operate a command
and control node from alifa hospital in
Gaza City they have weapons stored there
and are prepared to respond to an
Israeli military operation against the
facility so this is I'm just telling you
what we as the um intelligence Community
assesses is happening in Gaza City how
Hamas is using these hospitals to
operate but absolutely we do not want to
see a firefight in a hospital where
there are innocent civilians Maya
there's a really bizarre moment there so
they admit something that basically
everybody has known and then she's like
oh and Hamas is ready to defend it like
really are you guys talking to Hamas
about what they're doing at that
hospital I mean I don't think Hamas is
talking to anybody but I but I will say
this I think a big mistake that's being
made and it's it goes back on what I was
saying
before Hamas and the West talk different
languages to the West a hospital is
something that keeps people safe to
Hamas the a hospital is something that
keeps them safe because they know that
they can use the West's sensitivity to
their own they mock us for this they
laugh at us for this they build 36
hospitals in Gaza and I don't know if
you've seen the size of Gaza but it's
not that big 36 hospitals for what it's
Hamas speak a language of terrorism and
it is not the same language that the
West speak they cook babies and if you
can't imagine that it's because you're
not speaking the language I think Israel
is doing a very good job and trying very
hard to act as an interpreter to deal
with Kamas on the level that they
deserve to be dealed with because this
is not a hospital this is an
infrastructure that has been created
under the pretense of a hospital and to
try and convey that in a way to the West
in a way that the West will understand
it but it's a
struggle Amy I give you the final word
today
well I find it really
interesting just from a zoomed out
perspective how Obsessed the world is
with the intricate details of every
single step along the way that Israel
has to defend itself it does reveal this
certain hyper fixation on this addiction
Fe this fetish to cure scrutinize Israel
and only Israel uh in uh in defending
itself I mean there are so many causes
around the world and it just always rubs
me in the this very curious way of like
it's amazing every military tactic that
Israel has been implementing to defend
itself gets scrutinized and you have to
ask yourself why why why the one Jewish
state that has to defend itself here um
why does it get subject to the scrutiny
and then you can have a discussion on
what's legitimate criticism and what's
not but just the to the extent that
people are hyper fixating on every
detail of the military campaign must beg
the question of this double standard of
why Israel uh gets this kind of
attention um as opposed to any other
conflicts around the world that don't
get nearly as much um it makes the case
for you know describing the uh you know
the anti- Zionism is certainly a mask
for anti-Semitism and I would just end
on the idea that the one silver lining
in all of this is that it's very hard to
fight evil when it's op Fus skated when
it's hidden behind fancy slogans and
things like that but now what we are
seeing in the aftermath of October 7th
is this gleeful unap Unapologetic
celebration of hamas's actions of
hamas's aims uh from The River To The
Sea uh you know uh there is only one
solution inat Revolution to the extent
that the masses even understand what
that means the point is it's clear as
day what the motives are the genocide of
Jews and the destruction of the Jewish
State the only Jewish state in the world
the only state in the world that's not
allowed to defend itself is the Jewish
one apparently and this is clear as day
being being broadcast and and celebrated
and this is what these movements stand
for so it's easier to fight evil when
you can see it clearly and that's the
one silver lining takeaway from all of
this if you had any Illusions about what
all of this was about it's here right in
front of
us